for everyone who says why should I vote  the election never comes down to one  vote that is very dangerous thinking and  it's also misguided and I'll tell you  why many of us have that thought I have  that thought why am I going to bother to  vote when the election never comes down  to just one vote  if we all choose to stay home who have  that thought  we will lose winnable elections so think  about yourself as part of a group a  group of people who realizes the  election never comes down to one ballot  but that all of us together saying  despite that fact we're going to vote we  actually do swing elections let's all of  us make sure that we voted